back live now of course we'll be here
live for six to talk more about your
weather
chris matthews is somewhere in this
stadium with me
i don't know where he's at but i'm
willing to bet he's probably stuck in
his mouth with a hot dog right now
and a soda not sure chris will send it
over to you
actually ted that's coming up but thank
you very much we appreciate that hey
we're standing here on the concourse
level
of the 150 million dollar las vegas
ballpark beautiful
facility here baseball is back in las
vegas joining me now is the senior vice
president
howard hughes corporation mr tom warden
you guys are responsible for bringing
this thing here to summerlin
fantastic yeah it turned out great chris
i i think we all thought it was going to
be really good when we were planning and
building this
but then when it got done we were like
oh my gosh it's even better than we
thought
and we had that season in 2019 which
eclipsed everything else it was the best
season ever so we went from being
down at cashman field to being in the
top stadium in
all of triple a baseball and we had a
tremendously successful year
well you mentioned it top ballpark and
all of baseball and it was voted number
one
among all baseball parks including major
league parks that's how nice this
facility is
there's a lot to it that went into it i
mean it's all about the fan experience
and
the food is tremendous the party decks
we got the berm where we have uh you
know all kinds of people bringing their
dogs certain days of the week
we have a pool in center field that is
really awesome and people can just
watch the game as you sit in the pool
when it gets hot in july or august
and we have all kinds of seating all the
way around it's a 360 design so you can
walk all the way around this stadium
and enjoy it from all these different
views it's just great to be back all
right tom thank you very much enjoy the
day i know you will
you bet there he is mr tom warden as we
get set for
minor league baseball it's back in las
vegas after 19
months away it's back we'll have much
more for you coming up at six o'clock
reporting live from the concourse of the
beautiful las vegas ballpark chris
matthews 8 sports now
looks great out there all right guys
thanks